hello everyone and welcome to round six
of the 2019 ranked HS classic tournament
it's Gehrig Mayer with the white pieces
against Magnus Carlsen Roach's champion
now Marr lost is the previous round the
young Vincent Kaymer
who broke his losing streak after losing
four games in a row so that was
fortunate for young Vincent but somewhat
unfortunate for for Gehrig Meier who is
still on only one point after five
rounds and well now he has to play
against Carlson so that's a privilege
and a great opportunity but then again
you are not very likely to win a lot of
points or are you will just have to see
now before we check out this game I
would just like to announce that fidei
has announced new regulations for the
world chess championship matches I will
put a link in the description below
probably the third link or something
like that as the first two are always
interviews with players and impressions
from the previous round but the most
important thing you have to know about
the future wilshire championship matches
in 2020 course and will face someone who
wins the candidates tournament is that
no longer will they played 12 games they
will play 14 games so less chances of
going into the rapid section of the
World Chess Championship match across
and said in the negotiations that he
would prefer 16 or even 18 games but the
organizers said that that would be too
long and it was just to drag out the
event another thing the players are not
allowed to agree to a draw before making
40 moves so after black makes the 40th
move they are only then allowed to go
for a draw now as for the s4 the price
found the price fund the the suggested
price fund is 2 million euro 60% going
to do winner 40% going to the loser of
the match and if the match does go into
the rapid section then it will be 55 to
2 to 45% you know the distribution of
the prize fund and also and this is one
thing that I particularly like for the
first 40 moves they will have 120
minutes without getting increment per
move so you have to finish your first 40
moves without any notice for the fur
60 moves you do reach time control after
move 40 then you are awarded additional
60 minutes but until you reach move 60
there is no time increment so you have
to be very careful with your time if you
even hope of playing a nice endgame so
those are pretty much the most important
things and another thing fede is no
longer taking a third party to organize
the water championship event Fida will
now be in charge so courtesy of the new
field president Arkady dvorkovich
so that's a bit of the news from the
chess world now returning to this game
we do have some nice footage compliments
of the Greinke chess classic video team
but we are gonna go check it out
somewhat later so Mar has the white
pieces and he opens with Knight to f3
the red is on the board Knight to f6 by
crossing g3 g6 so the Kings Indian
attack Bishop to g2 Bishop to g7 and now
both players Castle so pretty
symmetrical d4 and now cross and break
symmetry with d6 and here we have b3 and
this is a well-known position there are
over 1500 games in the database we did
this exact same position and a lot of
moves have been played here c5 has been
placed here Knight bt7 was played he
five has been played c6 has been played
85 has been played nice the c6 has been
played but the move Carlsen played here
was never played before which is really
odd since there are over 1500 games in
the database with this exact same
position here across and played b5 and
there's no there's no reasonable
explanation what b5 is doing it's just
there well it's controlling the c4
squared that's for sure preparing to
think of the bishop to b7 but then again
why not I mean if if there's time and
your opponent allows it why not push b5
now that you see it seems like a
perfectly normal move but no one before
played it but okay brush up the b2 by
Marv Bishop to b7 motor spin Cato Knight
B to d2 and Knight B to d7 by Carlson
and now c4 and all your already you can
see that the b5 bone is very useful here
B captures on c4 and
Knight captures on c4b captures seems a
bit more principled but Mar has a very
nice idea how to exchange some pieces
with this line we have a five by Carlson
and I'll just look to see one getting
the rook into the game grab hold of the
semi-open C file and c5 by Carlson D
captures Knight captures and now comes
Bishop to deform our wants to trade here
trade Queens and hopefully play
something like ninety one exchange in
the light square Bishop Sango into an
end game where a crossing will have this
isolated a pawn and Mar will have a
two-to-one advantage on the Queen side
but Carlson is a bit stronger in the
center so night C to d7 Coulson doesn't
allow this and now a for locking death
born on a dark square we have looked to
a six now cross and is preparing to
bring this rook over to c6 and bring the
Queen over to a8 to create this powerful
Queen Bishop battery a so calls and
we'll be ready to capture on g2 if the
knight moves Knight to a3 preparing to
go to b5 with the night and cross and
said that he didn't really like this
idea of transferring the Knights to b5
as I did catch a glimpse of the
interview after the game he said that he
thought the night was more useful here
and that maybe some other moves were
better but then later as you'll see what
happens he he he did like it
Queen to eight Mikaelson Malcolm's
Knights the b5 and now rook to c6 as
planned country into rockin c1 rook
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
the e1 offering a trade of light square
Bishop says well cross and captures
Bishop captures with Knight captures and
now just rook the c8 and here across and
said that yes he was expecting Knight to
e7 and this is what Mara played and now
we don't really have a good square with
your rook if you want to keep your work
on the C file you can go something like
rook c7 but then just 95 you can go back
knight back to a7 you're not really
gaining anything here and you don't want
to play something like rook c7 to be
seven as then well you no longer have a
rook on an open file so here Crossland
had to go back look to d8 and he said he
didn't like this maneuver look to c8 the
DA that he should have just gone h5 or
something like that
but okay now Meyer grabs hold of the of
the open C file we have Queen to c2
Knights still controlling the CH square
and now comes a five by Carlson Bishop
to e3 and d5 so of course I've already
started moving his massive pawn Center
well it's not really a massive consider
but it is a very nice pawn Center d4 is
ready we have nice to see six attacking
the rook here rook to e8 and now comes
Bishop to d2 marna wants to eliminate
cross ins a five point there's really
not much Clausen can do about it and
then he wants to start pushing his two
connected passed pawns on the Queen side
we have Knight to e4 by Carlsen going
after the bishop here and our just
Knight captures on e5 we have looked the
c8 attacking the Queen here Queen to a2
and now Knight d2 f6 going back and the
now comes Bishop the e1 not allowing
this Knight capture Sundy to business
and we have Knight to c3 now attacking
the Queen here Bishop captures and c3
you do have to capture it as the bishop
no longer controls the knight on a five
so it must be captured with Bishop
captures rook captures and now comes b4
by white and here Carson has to figure
out how to go about this he wants to
start pushing his central pawns of
course and create a past D pawn but he
also has to be very careful the the two
connected passed pawns on the Queen side
that Meier has are also very strong so
here I believe this is the D position
that we have on the footage here solo
just check it out
here we have Carlsen oh sorry that's my
er but we also need that so let's check
that out as well just checking out the
position not really sure which position
it is and here we have nice footage of
course and where I believe it is this
position yeah there's the Queen on a 8
King there bishop knight on f6 and to
central phones it's not an easy decision
although on the footage you can see that
he already played Bishop to f8 which is
one of the two ideas that he was
considering and here you can also see
that he has he shaved his beard but I
still don't have I I still have a
beardless photo for him
to use on the left so for the moment we
have the the bearded one but okay
here the choice is basically between d4
starting to push your passport
immediately or butter up the f8 just
going after the b4 pawn forcing White's
to deal with this and here we have Queen
to be to the pawn is defended and only
now d4 and now although cross and took
away the e3 and f4 squares from our and
the knight would really enjoy one of
those squares to get back into the game
this is exactly what Mark should have
done he should have gone night to e3
- somehow activate this night as soon as
possible you of course cannot capture
because Queen captures rook but here Mar
went III and in an interview after the
game cross I said that he really didn't
like this III idea practically you know
giving black a fast deep on for free
cousin says that well described this
move as somewhat suicidal but okay
Knights the e4 by Carlsen he captures
pawn captures and now comes at night the
b3 introducing the knight back into the
game and now you are free to start
pushing your own past bones
we have d3 by Carson the past pawn is
ready to be pushed
ruk the c1 and here comes rook captures
and c1 the Carlsen also a very
interesting line was Bishop captures on
before and after this trade attacking
the Queen Queen be 1 and now d2 and here
it would be it would be very hard to
deal with this with the white knights
still being stuck here you can't keep an
eye on the a4 point and keep an eye on
the d1 square as well so after Queen b3
Queen captures attacking the knight and
now you don't really have all that much
you have to bring the right into the
game you get captures White Queen
captures this night but now you no
longer control the d1 square you have
two queens in the game and that's pretty
much it captures captures and you would
have a bishop and the Queen against the
Queen you would have to you know play a
lot more moves the wind is but it is of
course a winning position so Carson
didn't go for this line he decided to go
for rook captures and c1 Queen captures
and c1 and now Queen captures an A for
getting rid
this a four pawn now white no longer has
to connect the past pawns on the Queen
side and this b4 point is is very weak
so even though Mara was up upon a few
moments ago now he will loss lose both
connected passed pawns on the Queen side
Queen to c4 going after the d3 pawn so
you don't want to capture it just yet
first night the c5 defending the d3 pawn
and now if you if you're considering why
not just capture and then capture on d3
the problem is if you capture it of
course black will not recapture black is
just gonna go Queen d1 check and after
you block this as it is the only move
Queen captures you win back the piece
King G - and now d2 there's no stopping
b1 you just get another Queen and window
game so not possible to trade here 95 we
have nice to d2 now blocking the D pawn
and now comes Queen to a1 Bishop h6 was
also a possibility
and then after f4 blocking the bishop
only then queen d1 check and after
Knight 2 f1 then nice to e6 but here you
would probably have to bring the bishop
back maybe maybe something again like a
bishop here and then go over night here
night here night here night here and
then you know wreak havoc in White's
camp but again cousin had a different
idea after this night study to move he
didn't go for this he went the Queen to
a1 check immediately
we have Knights to f1 and now comes D to
already the point is pushed the knight
of course kind of captured as its pinned
we have Knights to e3 finally
introducing this Knight into the game
freeing up the g2 Square for white King
and now Knights the e6 again it's a it's
a very interesting idea to get this
night all the way to a one for example
after the bishop returns here control
after the bishop will be controlling
here night here Queen will have to guard
the c2 squared night here and it will
could be very dangerous
Queen to b3 by white again you have to
control the d1 square twice now comes
Queen to e1 and here we have King to g2
if you start pushing the pawn
immediately with b5 then you get nice
the c5 with an attack on the Queen and
after
in d1 now you get nice to e4 of course
white cannot capture as you will just
get sorry about that
another queen into the game here you're
threatening to win DF to pawn which
would very quickly end in victory and
after Queen f3 you would just get Knight
to c3 now controlling the d1 square
twice and after pretty much any move
white makes you just bring a queen into
the game win some material and that's
pretty much it if b6 is post you will go
Bishop not King Bishop d6 control the BH
square with the bishop and again Europe
a piece you're gonna win this game
so after Queen to e1 we have King to g2
and now feel free to pause the video and
try to find the best move for black here
I'll give you a couple of seconds while
I have a nice simple my water for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
finder of sneaky tactics and for those
of you who just want to enjoy it show
here Carlsen played Bishop captures on
b4 it's just a nice move because of
course you cannot capture the bishop you
no longer have control of the d1 square
and not only that after this pawn is
promoted to a queen you can't just
capture it and give back the piece
because your queen is hanging and you
can't capture here because then you'll
be down a queen so it's not possible to
capture the bishop here Queens the b2
was played and now cross and just pushes
h5 with H for not allowing black to push
H for himself and now Bishop goes back
to a5 as now there there definitely is
danger of capturing the bishop we have
Queen to b8 check crossing blocks with
the knight Knight to f8 and now comes
Queen to a8 attacking the bishop so now
if cross and brings the Queen into the
game yes you can trade but then white
will win this Bishop here so first cause
the moves Bishop to c3 now Queen to c6
again harassing this bishop Queen to c1
and the now comes Queen to d5 and now
again Knight to c6 and here I think
everyone was saying that says it was
once again saying that this is
definitely the best maneuver
knighted before to see to to e one check
but a constant did not go for it because
we have Queen to see for and now again
you could go for an ID for this a night
to eat one check which seems to cause a
lot of complications for white but cost
and again goes a bunch of j5u again
offers a trade of queens and of course
Myer declines this we have Queen to d5
again keeping an eye on the bishop also
keeping an eye on the d1 square Bishop
to b4 we have Queen to be five again
harassing the bishop we have Queen to c3
now defending the bishop and now Queen
back to d5 with double control of the d1
square
queen to see one now again Queen to b5
Mayer of course hoping for a repetition
as white cannot seek for a seek any
advantage your only black can push it
back to c3 and now Queen to a for
keeping an eye on the d1 square from
there Bishop to d4 now and now comes
Knight to d1 and here came to g7 by
cross and not allowing any back back
rank sneaky checks the king will be very
safe there as the bishop is keeping eye
on this diagonal and the now comes King
to f3 here Mar gets the idea that he
will finally win this d2 pawn with his
king and now comes Bishop to f6 King to
e2 getting ready to capture the d2 pawn
and now comes Knight the d4 check we
have King to d3 and now comes Queen to
be one chick cousin has a very nice idea
he allows her to capture his past pawn
king capture son b2 but now comes Queen
to e4 and interestingly this is move 58
you need to make two more moves to reach
time control and I don't know if I
didn't really catch if my resigned in
this game or his time ran out but normal
moves were played I believe it was in
this position that Jeremiah resigned the
game or even if he didn't if his time
ran out he most likely would have
resigned if that was the case because
there's nothing to do here if you try
something like I mean there's really
nothing you you want to do the Queen can
come here you can also play a knight of
three
check for example if if you play some
like night fe3 to block this then just
night if three check wins the Queen on a
four and if you move the Queen so black
it doesn't win the Queen let's say you
move it here to control this Square
still doesn't help as now you'll see how
black wins it's actually a very nice
mate in one so let's just enjoy it
Knight B 3 of course this is mate in one
yeah the knight control C 1 and D 2 and
you can see that the queen is slicing
all the way here and all the way here
just a very nice very nice position not
to be in as the game didn't reach this
disposition here it ended after Queen 3
for sure another very nice game by
Carlsen under very nice victory by cross
and cross and is now on for a four and a
half out of six so which is pretty much
insane and we're not gonna be showing
the standings as we are planning at
least one more video from round 6 of
Greinke chess classic so that's about it
for for this game once again
do check out if you're interested in the
video regulations regarding the World
Chess Championship matches the link will
be in the description below also
impressions from the previous round in
the in the description below and I don't
know if there are any interviews
available so far but if they are I will
also put them in the description below
so I hope you enjoyed those as well I
would also like to thank Michael Holland
Martin was the room micro vouching John
cousins and our own me - girl for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos we
are thankful for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and yeah that's
that's about it thank you all I will see
soon and he'll have an excellent rest of
your Friday